et tes parents ils font quoi
mon père il est médecin ma mère est
pharmacienne dans ma famille c'est
quasiment que des médecins qu'on rigole
à la maison beaucoup ça va non si on
rigole parce que j'ai une famille hyper
ouverte
vraiment ils sont ils peuvent ouvrir sur
tous les sujets et tout c'est cool mais
par contre quand je leur ai dit que je
voulais être humoriste être artiste ils
m'ont vachement dit attention ça va être
dur il vaut mieux que tu fasses du
théâtre en amateur et qu'il fasse un
vrai métier à côté
psychologue ah non parce que je leur ai
dit est-ce que je pourrais être
psychologue ils m'ont dit en psychologue
c'est nul
je pense que je reprenne les trucs de
mes parents la pharmacie de ma mère tout
ça mais bon ça ça m'intéressait pas trop